when it seems that I was detained for
taking photos in a public space
it appears with the job at that point
you no longer have that
Shawny is an award-winning photographer
who's been published by National Public
Radio fate magazine and the Los Angeles
Times I guess you could sort of love my
photography into street photography and
documentary photography you know I live
in Hollywood so I tend to focus on you
know my community where I live on june
2nd 2013 me was detained by Los Angeles
Police Department officers in Hollywood
California today is the first day Mia
spent any significant time here since
that day these images were shot by
several body cameras and he wears when
he goes out to shoot and he provided an
edited version of Jun seconds events two
recent TV is this a body camera
it's just attached just in my bag during
that day I was actually photographing a
man who I have been photographing for
about five or six years LAPD showed up
through a tenant dispute involving this
apartment complex and then I began Toto
graphing them from the public sidewalk
after they finished talking to the
tenants they focused their attention on
B and then they they walked across the
driveway over the fence through the
backyard engaging yet defense my beam
that's answer
we showed the video to Andy Neiman the
officer in charge of the LAPD's Media
Relations section certainly we do not
prevent people from taking photographs
when they are in areas that they have a
lawful right to be which is public space
but Nieman offered this caveat if their
physical proximity to the investigating
officers becomes interfering where an
officer has to stop what they're doing
to admonish that individual that they're
too close or could you stand back
because they are distracting from the
officers business then that that's where
it becomes an issue but he showed us
where he was standing and the fence he
stayed behind I'm basing this distance
like on a baseball field and to me you
know that's like this I walked over
there's probably the distance from home
to first base which is probably about a
90 feet in fact me says he was at such a
significant distance that the two
officers had to go out of their way to
detain him on the sidewalk you can see
how far they had to walk from way down
here to their patrol unit and then they
drove all the way around the block to
the other side to where I was where I
was taking the pictures from
maybe a new dancer yes well football
para pasar por tu cara de lima bean
contains her interviewing interfering
with the police investigate
okay I was they doing that so now people
have a right to take pictures in public
space and that includes photographing
them you know and when they don't that
creates a problem that curbs behavior it
curbs you know First Amendment rights it
it even you know it limits the press it
restricts trends Oparin see I just think
it comes down to people have the right
to know what goes on in their
communities and in public the officers
took all of these cameras but didn't
find this one until arriving at the
Hollywood community police station
and we're just trying to resolve this so
you can go on your way but if you want a
custom supervisor that creates
he was never booked that day for
interfering with a police investigation
he was released from the police station
without charge which raises the question
was he really interfering or just taking
photos for recent TV
I'm Paul Detrick